The Tick Tock party that's the focus of
tonight's angle
[Music]
well Mr China came to Washington today
and it was quite a spectacle we have
heard important concerns about the
potential for unwanted foreign access to
U.S data and potential manipulation of
The Tick-Tock U.S ecosystem
our approach has never been to dismiss
or trivialize any of these concerns we
will firewall protected U.S data from
unwanted foreign access can you do
surveillance of other Americans we will
protect the U.S user data and fire it
all from all unwanted foreign access
it's a commitment that we've given to
the committee I wanted to hear you say
with 100 certainty that neither bitness
nor Tick Tock employees can Target other
Americans with similar surveillance
techniques that you did with the
journalists
again I don't disagree with the
characterization characterization I
think it's our commitment that we will
not be influenced by any government on
these issues doj is investigating this
this surveillance right now a ban is
only a short-term way to address
Tick-Tock and a data privacy bill is the
only way to stop tick tock from ever
happening again in the United States
that your parent company by dance
currently can access user data yes let's
uh we have to be more specific
um yes after project Texas no I'm not
asking after project Texas I'm asking
now yes some user data as public data
congresswoman which means everybody
what's interesting to me is that you
have used the word transparency over a
half a dozen times in your opening
testimony and subsequently again in your
answers to my colleagues yet the
interesting thing to me is that bite
dance your parent company has gone out
of their way to hide an airbrush
corporate structure ties to the CCP
that was wild now it was back in July of
2020. I don't know if you remember this
but I pressed the former CIA director
and then Trump Secretary of State Mike
Pompeo on the threat posed by tick tock
shouldn't we be considering right now
tonight a ban on Chinese social media
apps especially Tick Tock I don't want
to get in front of the president but
it's something we're looking at would
you recommend that people download that
up on their phones tonight tomorrow
anytime uh currently only if you want
your private information in the hands of
the Chinese Communist Party
now exactly one month after that
interview air then president Trump
signed an executive order that would
have essentially banned Tick Tock in the
United States but in June of 2021 Biden
fully reversed the ban now since then
the Intel assessments about Tick Tock
have only gotten worse
one-sixth of American Youth say they're
constantly on Tick Tock that's a that's
a loaded gun
so why hasn't Biden reverse course first
because China owns Biden now we know
from Biden bank records that his family
has made big money there and Biden's
team is doing everything in its power to
suck up to China Daily
at this point there's literally nothing
that the CCP can do that's going to push
Biden off his super engagement mission
so why would Biden risk offending his
benefactor over some stupid app
and the second reason the tick tock app
is still in the Apple Store is China's
Army of high paid lobbyists Consultants
law firms and even former congressmen
they're crawling all over Capitol Hill
flexing their muscle and they're making
their case
now these people are what Trump was
referring to when he said drain the
swamp
fine with selling out their own country
as long as that monthly retainer check
doesn't bounce
and then there's the senior staff at
Tick Tock itself now they're even worse
refusing to answer simple questions
about the persecution of religious
minorities in China
do you agree that the Chinese government
has persecuted the uyghur population if
you use our app and you open it you will
find our users who give all sorts that's
not my question well is daily concerning
to hear about all accounts of Human
Rights abuse please
it's a pretty easy question
congresswoman I'm here to discard Tick
Tock and what we do as a platform
well indifferent shared by folks like
Michael Beckerman tick tock's head of
public policy now you saw him sitting
behind Mr Chu today at the hearing with
a very smug self-satisfied look on his
face well Harry was three months ago on
CNN
do you acknowledge that the Chinese
government has these uyghurs and others
in contrary concentration camps well
that's not something that I that I focus
on we work for a Chinese government
company and the Chinese are accused of
concentration camps and ethnic genocide
you can you can look you can find all
this content on Tick Tock why won't you
acknowledge that I mean I can I'm just
not I'm just not an expert on what's
happening in China
Pond scum
how is Beckerman different from any
senior member of the Communist party at
this point on this issue look he does
their propagandizing for them
as long as bite dance owns Tick Tock the
CCP has the ability to vacuum up as much
information on users of tick tock as
they want
contrary to what Mr Chu was trying to
argue today
do any American dance employees in China
including Engineers currently have
access to U.S data this is a complex
topic today all data it's not that
complex yes or no do they have access to
user data we are after project Texas is
they aren't done the answer is no today
there's still something we've heard
originally the ranking members here and
that he doesn't really see that project
Texas is going to be useful
no this is ludicrous at any time of day
or night
now and a year from now president XI or
any CCP official can demand user data
and he'll be given user data in fact
even Chu couldn't deny that top staff at
bite dance are in fact members of the
Communist Party logic would tell us that
there are fair number of your employees
or members of the Chinese Communist
party at least a dozen or so who have
access to this data isn't that so
again like I said I can ask one or two
people I we don't have a policy
so sleazy now even though we knew that
China was stealing user data we've
allowed tick tock's reach to metastasize
now there are staggering 150 million
Tick-Tock users in the United States Mr
Chu was bragging about that today
so this begs the question
why didn't we even need a congressional
hearing at this point no matter what chu
says about corporate firewalls and
transparency he ultimately answers to
the CCP he slips up and he knows that
just like other CEOs he could be
disappeared overnight
in principle we want to provide you know
a good experience for our users in
general we actually put in more
restrictions to make sure that our
teenagers get a better experience the
majority of people who use help platform
use it for positive experiences there's
so many people left the app it's a great
experience
yeah the uyghurs are having a real
positive experience
and when he didn't want to answer
questions he used a tried and true trick
in response
would you commit to not selling your
data anyone I can get back to you on the
details I can get back to you on the
specifics oh look into the specifics I
don't have specifics Congressman I need
to check on these specifics I I need to
look at the specifics of the report
congressman and I can get back to you on
that but I want to be precise and I'll
get back to you
all day long Mr Chu labored to reassure
the committee that Tick Tock is working
hard on their new corporate plan to
cordon off the operation from prying
eyes
we have design project Texas to protect
U.S user interests and to move forward
here in the U.S again it's the
protections of storing American data on
American soil by an American company
looked after by American Personnel now
with scrambling to Stave off an all-out
band so Tick Tock proposed a 1.5 Billion
Dollar corporate reorganization kept
referring to it called project Texas
very clever insisting that all data
would be stored in the U.S and as he
said those servers would be run by
Americans at Oracle
but just recently after studying that
very proposal the committee on foreign
investments said that that proposal
failed to address the data vulnerability
issue only getting the company out of
Chinese hands would address that problem
China's 2017 National Intelligence law
states very clearly that quote any
organization or citizen shall support
assist and cooperate with State
intelligence in other words bite dance
and also your Tick Tock employees that
live in China they must cooperate with
Chinese intelligence whenever they are
called upon if the CCP tells bite dance
to turn over all data that Tick Tock has
collected inside the U.S congressman
first I'm Singaporean
um that's fine but there are employees
of yours and bite dances in China we
understand this concern we built
something where we take that data and
put it Out Of Reach
even Democrats didn't seem to be buying
it today
that Mr Chu was creepy not credible
I still believe that the Beijing
communist government will still control
and have the ability to influence what
you do and you're trying to give the
impression that you're a good actor but
the commitments that we would seek to
achieve those goals are not being made
but throughout the day and it was very
long and getting hammered by both
parties the London and Harvard educated
Mr Chu kind of kept us cool
it was almost like he knew that in the
end Biden would never sign a bill
Banning Tick-Tock into law it was just a
few weeks ago that the White House had
come up with a middle ground suggesting
that bite dance sell Tick-Tock then that
would mollify concerns of both parties
and Americans across the country well so
much for compromising with the Chinese
today just hours before that Hill
Herring China gave the symbolic middle
finger to Biden announcing that it was
rejecting the idea of selling Tick Tock
huh I wonder why
now will The Establishment ever learn
that you cannot meet China halfway on
any issue like this
their aim is simple
it's to conquer the United States in any
way they ultimately can through
influence presence what have you
and this would mean it would be fine for
many in the regime media by the way who
seem to have already given up on America
check out how the New York Times
characterize the question facing
Washington about whether to ban
Tick-Tock this was today
some of the world's largest news
organizations including the New York
Times now have Tick-Tock accounts
meaning that shutting down the app could
appear to be shutting down the spread of
fact-based news to counter Chinese
disinfo
well first that the New York Times will
ever be a reliable counter to China is
laughable plus remember all their
efforts to counter so-called covet
misinformation
now the only answer here is to force
Biden's hand
Congress must immediately pass
legislation to ban The Tick Tock app in
the United States long since time
then Biden can choose to protect the
priorities of the CCP or to protect
national security and privacy concerns
of the American people the choice is
quite simple and that's the angle hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else